Narrator: It's been 10 years
since "Shark Tank"
ignited America's
entrepreneurial spirit,
and we are still blazing
a trail.
For those who take their fate
into their own hands
by working hard...
Who wants to join
our worldwide mission
to make parenting easier?
...by working smart...
Bethencourt: I was fascinated
by the idea of creating
an entirely new type
of pet food.
Narrator:
...by thinking big...
Beaudry: Welcome to the world
of floating.
...and chasing their dreams.
This entire product
has been my life.
I put this together on my own.
And tonight, co‐founder
of RSE Ventures
and vice chairman of the
Miami Dolphins Matt Higgins
returns to the Tank.
You've been trapped
in this prison
of an inflated valuation.
But our valuation is fair.
You're ruining people.
Throw me a bone, Daddy.
[ Dog whines ]
♪♪
Narrator:
First into the Tank
is a business
based on relaxation.
♪♪
My name's Scott Swerland.
And I'm Joe Beaudry.
We're from
Seattle, Washington,
and we're seeking $500,000
for 5% of our company,
Urban Floats.
‐Ooh.
‐God.
Sharks, this is
your escape pod.
It will take you away
from the stresses
and anxieties of life,
giving you better focus,
faster recovery,
and reduced pain.
All you need to do
is get in this pod,
and your life will improve.
Welcome to the world
of floating.
Floating is a form of peaceful,
weightless hydrotherapy
where you step into this
sensory‐controlled environment
and feel the calming effects
on the mind and body.
It's a trend that's exploding,
and we're leading the charge.
Sharks, you simply show up
to one of our high‐end
Urban Float spas,
where you will check into
your own private
relaxation sanctuary,
where you will float
weightlessly
in 200 gallons of water,
made buoyant by 1,200 pounds
of Epsom salt.
You'll leave all the stresses
and noise of your life behind,
and when you leave this pod,
you will return to life
renewed, refreshed,
and revived.
Better focus!
Faster recovery!
Less physical pain!
Floating makes everything
you do in life better.
Sharks, we're seeing
incredible success,
and we would love
your help
to share the benefits
of floating
with everyone
around the world.
How many of you Sharks
want to swim ‐‐
I should say "float" ‐‐
with this proven team?
Greiner:
So, many years ago,
they came out
with float tanks, right?
Creepier looking, for sure.
‐Yes, yes.
This is much better‐looking.
So, I think
the biggest difference
between
the old days and today ‐‐
this is something
that people look at
and they want to get in.
They want
to experience this.
‐Yeah.
‐There is music options.
There is lighting options.
You can really
take this experience
as far as
you want to go with it.
And on top of that,
we build our centers to be
very kind of high‐end,
more spa‐like.
Does each person get
a new salt bag
or is it the same salt bag
the last guy rotated in?
So, what we do is,
the entire body of water
goes through a filtration system
no less than four times
where it's heated,
treated, hit with UV,
it's sanitized,
and then back in.
The water's actually cleaner
than your drinking faucet.
That is the highest priority.
Higgins: First of all,
I love the space.
The Dolphins ‐‐
we're doing a ton of work
around recovery
and how to get athletes
back on their feet
as soon as possible,
and float tanks
and meditation
is a big part of it.
I want to hear about
the business a bit.
I'm missing ‐‐
Okay, great.
Urban Float has
four corporate stores.
We've spent
the last five years
kind of perfecting the box.
So, we opened up
the largest float center
in the United States
in downtown Seattle,
and ‐‐ and about two years ago,
we got into franchising.
Someone came and banged
on our door and said,
"Hey, we really want
to do this."
She actually
came back last month
and bought four more, uh,
with the profits
from her first store.
Nice.
We have audited statements
for our franchising.
We've ‐‐ We've registered
in every state.
How did you guys fund
all this?
Where did the money
come from?
So, we opened up our first store
real bootstrap,
and, uh, we did that
with friends and family.
And how much
did you raise?
$300,000,
and we've taken another
$1 million of our profits
and opened up
the additional stores.
Does it cost 300k
to open a location,
the average location?
It costs ‐‐
It costs about $500,000
to $600,000.
Wow.
How many beds in a $500,000
to $600,000 ‐‐
Including the equipment,
which ‐‐
So how many beds
in a $500,000 ‐‐
‐Six.
Prototypical store is six.
‐Six beds.
Yep.
For half a mill,
you get six beds
plus the front office.
‐Yes, sir.
‐Yeah.
This is bought from a company
that makes them,
so anybody could buy them?
‐Yes.
‐You didn't design it?
We did not design this, no.
Higgins:
Tell us about the customer.
What's the model?
Are you doing a membership?
Are you doing, you know,
one‐time?
Yeah, so, we do have
a range of offerings
to get people
to float regularly.
We have a single float session
for $45
to come and try it out.
‐That's not bad.
‐Yeah.
Oh, the first time.
The first time, right?
Yeah.
And then we ask people,
you know, really, you've
got to give this three tries.
Like, you can't
just go to a gym
and get ripped
on one workout, right?
You have to invest
a little bit of time.
Tell us what
the membership fees are.
The membership fees are ‐‐
unlimited is $150.
‐A month.
‐For the month.
‐Okay.
‐Yeah.
O'Leary: This year, what is
the model gonna make,
including the corporate‐owned
stores and the franchise fees
and the royalties
and everything?
We'll do $2.5 million.
We're on run‐rate
to do $2.5 million.
Pre‐tax, bot‐‐
to the bottom line.
No. Top ‐‐
Top‐end revenue.
I just ‐‐ I care about
cash flow, here.
About $600,000
in cash flow.
Okay.
And you put a price on this,
$500,000 for 5%.
$10 million.
Yep.
We are registered ‐‐
You know, it's not crazy.
‐Thank you.
Coming from you,
that means a lot.
‐Oh, he rarely says that.
‐Yeah, I know.
That does mean a lot.
So, how much debt does
this company have on it?
We've got
just about $1 million
of SBA financing
and bank debt.
Cuban: Guys, look.
Every five years,
there's something new
that athletes try first,
and then
it becomes popular.
I mean, the Mavs,
10 years ago,
started using cryotherapy.
Jason Kidd, Dirk used cryo,
until they didn't.
They like it.
"Oh, it's great.
It's great.
It's great."
"When was the last time
you used it?"
"Oh, I keep on
forgetting to go."
There's just so many ifs,
it just creates
too many concerns.
And for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mark.
John: You know,
$1 million in debt
is obviously ‐‐
it's a lot of money.
I don't believe
in your retail strategy.
I don't think there's anything
proprietary here.
I'm out.
♪♪
Greiner: Well, listen.
While I give you great kudos
for look, design, concept,
I don't want
to step into the Tank
with that kind of debt.
I'm out.
♪♪
Okay.
I like operators
that have cash flow.
I have to reflect
two things ‐‐
the risk inherent
in the business
and also,
the most important thing is,
there's only
one Mr. Wonderful
and what I always call
the Mr. Wonderful Premium.
Here's my offer.
I'm gonna give you 100k
in equity.
I want 15%, $400,000 of debt
at 9.5%, 36 months.
No flexibility.
Thank you for ‐‐
Greiner: Well, there is
another Shark.
‐Yeah. There is.
‐There is.
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Joe and Scott
have an offer from Kevin
for their floatation
spa company, Urban Float,
but Matt may also
be interested.
♪♪
I know that I could help you
by helping you get more traction
amongst sports teams.
My partner, Steve Ross,
is the owner of Equinox.
So, while I can't get you
into Equinox,
I can help you scale
a lot faster
than you're gonna do
on your own,
so I'd like to
make you an offer.
I'll give you $500,000
for 15% of the business.
♪♪
So, my offer is
the same amount of money.
It's just structured
differently.
Would you do
a straight debt deal?
I got to have some
upside on the equity.
The equity is ‐‐
is a bit of the kicker.
Why ‐‐ Why is that?
Uh...
Well, how much equity
are you offering Kevin
to do it
with all straight debt?
It would be, you know,
like, 2.5%.
See, now you're
concerning me a bit,
'cause I think
you're thinking small.
I know what it takes
to scale.
I'm gonna roll up my sleeves
with you,
but the idea that you're
focused too much on debt
because you don't want
to get diluted,
when you get me on board,
you get a standing source
of capital.
But why would you
want me to own
such a fraction
of the business?
Okay, so,
would you consider 7.5%?
♪♪
John: Let's think about it
like this.
He's one of the top marketers
and branders in the country.
You probably would pay
one of his companies
$1 million a year ‐‐
Yeah.
‐A year, right...
‐Mm‐hmm.
...to get this out,
so why are you thinking
only about the pennies
instead of the value?
Greiner: Yeah.
Would you consider 7.5%?
No, I'd consider 15%,
and you want me investing 15%.
Oh, my God.
You want him.
You want me
in this business.
I can't imagine
not taking this.
We can't do a deal for 15%.
Can you meet us somewhere?
Beaudry: We can do...
This deal is floating away.
I mean, I'm willing to ‐‐
Think how much more money
you will be making.
So much more.
The middle between
5% and 15% is 10%.
Can we do 10%?
I'll ‐‐ I'll ‐‐
Can we please do 10%?
And we will perform for you
like no one's business.
People love this.
‐This guy can sell.
‐I love it.
‐I'm ready.
‐"People love it."
All right, here we go.
Here we go. Here we go.
Let's just put ‐‐ let's just
put it out, all right?
We're gonna be
co‐founders together.
We're gonna make a company
that's gonna be
well over $100 million
in a couple years.
If you do 12.5%,
we have a deal right now.
♪♪
‐Congratulations.
‐Yeah! That's right!
There you go, Matt.
Congrats.
I love it! I love it!
I'm gonna float.
Oh, my God.
Oh, man.
‐Give me a hug, man.
‐Come on. Let's go in.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Oh, my gosh.
And by the way, I'm out.
‐Congrats.
‐What?
‐[ Laughs ]
Yeah! [ Laughs ]
That is insane.
What a rush.
Swerland: You know,
at the end of the day,
a couple extra points
to get Matt in there,
and the horsepower he brings,
you know, that's okay.
John: I love when people
ignore you, Kev.
I mean, they didn't even
think about you.
Greiner: Oh, my God.
That was so perfect for you.
I was ready to jump up and go,
"What are you doing?"
Good job, Matt.
Thank you.
♪♪
Not some of my returns ‐‐
practically 100%
have come from companies
run by women.
A few months ago, I delivered
a keynote address for Facebook
about small businesses.
I met Sheryl Sandberg,
their Chief Operating Officer.
It turns out we both have
the same objective ‐‐
giving more women
a chance in business.
It got me thinking that
the Sharks should send
some of our own
female entrepreneurs
for a workshop
at their headquarters,
and it's all happening today.
The entrepreneurs
are here to learn
how to harness
the power of social media
to help them
grow their businesses.
Hello, everybody.
Margulis: Being at Facebook
today is a great opportunity.
We're here workshopping
and learning
from all the amazing and
smart people that work here.
Video is a really important
thing to start to master,
so we're gonna get into
some things that you can do.
We're gonna talk about
the auction and delivery system,
how to optimize ads based on
your different business goals.
Instagram stories has
400 million daily active users,
so it's definitely where we're
seeing consumer time shift.
Chen: Social media's
not just advertising,
but it's actually how
we connect with our customers
and find out what
they're interested in.
The main thing
I'm taking away from today
is how to compete
on social media
and to create bigger
and better content
to reach more customers.
I used to make this joke
that men still run the world
and it's not going so well.
[ Laughter ]
I think we need more women
running businesses,
and I think that starts
with each of you.
Sheryl Sandberg is one of
the most influential women
in the world,
and here we are,
two moms with
a little swimsuit company
getting advice from her.
It's incredible.
I think we all come across
the same thing
where the female identity
is tied to our appearance.
How do you get men
to think with you
instead of about you?
It's such an important question,
right, in the era of #MeToo,
when so many things
that went on for so long
and still happen
need to change.
You come in as the hardheaded
businesswoman you are.
If someone on the
other side of the table
isn't treating you that way,
you turn around,
and you walk out.
Lim: Women in business,
we're really
no different from men,
and yet there's this disparity.
And I think,
for me personally,
I have three
young daughters at home,
and I just want to show them
that the sky's the limit.
I'm just excited
for the example
you all are setting
for women and girls.
You've inspired me today,
and I know you'll
inspire all of them.
Nanda: I'm so grateful to
"Shark Tank" and Facebook
for creating this opportunity
for female entrepreneurs
to come together
and help us create a community.
O'Leary: This is a great day
for women entrepreneurs ‐‐
getting together,
supporting each other,
and realizing that they can win
the game of business
anywhere on Earth, any time.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is an advancement
in food technology.
♪♪
I love dogs.
‐Oh, my God. Hey!
‐[ Laughs ]
Hi. My name
is Ryan Bethencourt.
I'm a biotech entrepreneur
and CEO.
I'm seeking $550,000
for 5% of my company...
Oh!
...Wild Earth.
Wow.
Sharks, as an animal lover,
I'm concerned about
how we feed our pets.
What's really in their food ‐‐
with so many ingredients
we can't even pronounce,
and major pet‐food recalls
happening frequently.
In addition, pet obesity
is a serious problem,
with fillers and fats being
added to conventional pet food,
and there's another problem.
It's really bad
for the environment,
polluting our water,
soil, and air.
As a biotech entrepreneur
with a track record
in cellular agriculture,
I was fascinated
by the idea of creating
an entirely new type
of pet food.
Introducing Wild Earth,
a cultured, protein dog food
made with human‐grade koji.
Koji is the secret sauce
in miso, soy sauce, and sake.
It's added to boost
the umami flavor
craved by billions worldwide.
Koji is rich in protein
and contains
the 10 essential amino acids
that dogs require
in their food.
And they love it,
so I'll show you.
So, we've got
Freddy and Josie.
So, hey, guys.
When's the last time Freddy
and Josie ate anything?
‐About a week ago.
‐This morning.
[ Laughs ] So ‐‐
and, they are fans.
Proof's in the pudding.
So, Sharks,
it's time to get serious
with how we feed our pets
more safely,
sustainably, and ethically.
I invite you to join
the koji revolution.
‐They want more.
‐They do want more.
‐I mean, they're looking.
‐Yeah, we'll give them more.
I think they'll nibble some
as well.
Essentially, you're forcing
dogs into veganship
whether they want it or not.
♪♪
What do dogs crave?
Protein, right?
Whether it's animals...
Say I'm a dog
and I like meat.
I‐I'm screwed with you.
Well...
‐Just ignore this guy.
‐Yeah, so...
No, but I think ‐‐ I think
it's a real question.
I'd be happy to take you on.
I'm happy to discuss this
Kevin, because the thing is,
if you talk to most pets ‐‐
most vets.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, most vets.
Most pets will eat
pretty much anything.
Right.
But most vets agree
that a meat‐free diet
is actually just as healthy
as a meat‐based diet.
I'm living in a vegan world
these days,
because my son
is dating a vegan woman,
and I got to eat vegan
on Tuesdays.
Welcome to the club.
What happens is they take
supplements like candy.
‐Why do you take supplements?
‐Wait a minute. Wait a minute.
Women usually just tell
the boyfriend what to do.
Now they're telling
the boyfriend
and his father what to do?
Well, if I want to see him,
I got to go eat vegan
on Tuesday.
[ Laughs ]
I'm afraid to ask this,
but can we try it?
What I have to say ‐‐
and I will bring it over...
This will be like Tuesdays
with your son.
Let me scoot over here.
Bethencourt:
One for everyone.
Are we gonna regret this?
‐No, no. Definitely not.
‐Okay, all right.
Wait, you're saying we can
actually taste it?
Yes.
Thank you.
Thank you. Mark.
Thank you, sir.
You're welcome.
Bethencourt: All right.
So, this is made for dogs,
but it's made in our facility.
This was made in
a human‐grade kitchen.
It's a flavor dogs love.
Yeah, I'm not happy
or unhappy.
It tastes like oatmeal.
Well, it's koji,
bacon flavor ‐‐
non‐animal‐based ‐‐
and peanut butter.
Dogs love it.
It's got over 10% koji.
So, we actually make koji
ourselves.
Is 10% enough protein?
Not off of treats.
You can't feed a dog
off treats.
These are treats?
They're not dog food.
Treats, and this is
our prototype kibble.
So, our treats are being ‐‐
we're releasing them in October,
and then our kibble,
we're shooting to release ‐‐
Wait a minute. Wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
I'm gonna ask the question
they're about to ask.
You just said something
really, really bad.
$550,000 for 5%.
That means that
you are saying
your company is worth
$11 million.
O'Leary:
It's a steal, Daymond.
You just said...
[ Clears throat ]
Operators are standing by.
It is a steal, Daymond,
for a multi‐billion‐dollar
company.
...some words called
"I just released it,"
or you're about to?
We're about to.
So, we're gonna be releasing
commercially in October.
How much sale did
you do of anything
to make this company worth
$11 million right now?
We did a lot of R&D.
Oh!
Uh‐oh.
You don't say.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
but they're skeptical of
Ryan's $11 million valuation
for his vegan dog food company,
Wild Earth,
which has not yet
hit the market.
Daymond, would it be helpful
if I told you a story?
Please tell me a story.
Okay, so I helped start
what's now called
the biohacker movement,
right?
At the end of 2008,
these companies
were going bankrupt ‐‐
these biotech companies ‐‐
and we basically bought
the bankrupt equipment
and starting building
little labs in our homes ‐‐
community labs.
That led to me co‐founding
the largest biotech accelerator
in the world.
It's actually called
IndieBio.
Wait, what does that
have to do with the valuation?
Like, what does that have
to do with the valuation?
So, our ‐‐ our last ‐‐
I'm just ‐‐
I'm missing something.
Yeah. Our last priced round
was actually led
by Felicis Ventures...
Sure.
...and Peter Thiel.
Yeah.
And they invested
in the potential of
the alternative protein
to totally disrupt
the $30 billion pet‐food market
just in the U. S. alone.
And how much did they invest?
How much did they invest?
They invested $2 million.
That's the total
you've taken in?
No, we've taken in a total
of $4 million, so we've ‐‐
You've taken in $4 million
for dog biscuits?
Mm‐hmm.
So, what problem
are you solving, again,
by making me eat
a very dry dog snack?
Yeah, so, there is no
future food leader
in the alternative protein space
in pet food.
But where do you get
the koji from?
So, we basically have created
our own strains of koji.
I'm a biotech guy.
My co‐founder is
a serial entrepreneur with me.
He is a hard‐core scientist.
He did his PhD at Princeton,
did his post‐doc at Harvard.
Yeah, huge pedigree.
I get all that.
You get it.
Where are you making it?
In our lab.
So, we have a lab where
we basically take sugar
as the raw feed stock,
we use our bioreactors,
and we continue to scale
our bioreactors.
We have our own strains of koji
that are highly efficient,
can be industrialized
to scale.
We use cells
and products of cells
to create
clean protein sources.
What does
this dog food cost
compared to
traditional dog food?
Right now, at our first
level of scale,
our COGS for the treats
is about $3.50,
and we'll be selling
the treats for $12.99.
‐That's a lot.
‐It's a premium product.
What is a typical
bag of treats?
$6 a bag.
And what about dog food,
let's say,
when you advance
into the dog food?
So, dog food,
we're at a premium scale.
So when we initially launch,
probably looking at
a $40 price point.
‐$40?
‐$40 for one bag?
Yep.
Wow.
So, you're looking
for alternative foods...
You got it.
...that are better
for the environment.
Better for the animals.
Better across the board,
right?
Yeah.
So question is,
when you raised the $4 million,
what was the valuation?
It was $7.5 million
pre‐money,
and then it was a $9.5 million
post‐money valuation.
How much equity do
you have to give up?
The founders own about
50% of the company,
a little less than 50%.
How much do you own?
About 20%.
‐And that's after conversion.
‐That's after conversion.
Y‐You basically convinced
somebody that dog food's
worth 7 million bucks
before you sold any of it.
Kevin, Kevin.
The U. S. market is
a $30 billion market.
If we want to talk numbers,
let's talk global markets.
Yeah, but families
can't afford to buy
incredibly expensive,
premium, you know,
vegan dog food.
There will be some families
that spend less...
John:
They'll eat it themselves.
...on their children
feeding them,
So, I have a question,
'cause you've been
observing the dogs
that obviously
been eating this.
Yes.
Over time, when you
force them to be vegan,
do they change?
Do they start wearing
tie‐dye and Birkenstocks,
and are they sort of
laid back?
Look, you're a very
credible guy,
but there is no friggin' way
in the world
I'm putting $11 million
on a dog food company that
hasn't sold anything yet.
And on top of that,
if you're successful,
all these dogs are gonna
start dreaming about meat,
just sitting
on the sofa going,
"Ohh, I wish
I could have some meat."
So, Kevin, let me stop you
for one second.
When you say "meat" ‐‐
When you say "meat,"
what meat do you think
goes into conventional
dog food?
I mean,
throw me a bone, Daddy.
I'm not giving you ‐‐
Chicken feathers and beaks.
Ain't gonna happen.
I'm out.
♪♪
Thank you, Kevin.
Your background
is very interesting.
You're very educated.
But when you come in here
and ask us
for over half a million dollars
for 5%
and I have no proof
of this concept whatsoever
and it's really expensive,
how can I invest in that?
I can't do that.
I have to go out.
♪♪
Okay, well,
thank you, Lori.
I'm sorry.
♪♪
I think the shame
with your business, right,
is that we can't even hear
what you're pitching
because you've been trapped
in this prison
of an inflated valuation.
You seem like an amazing guy.
You're probably a genius.
But you represent what happens
when you jack up
that valuation
and you keep pushing it up.
And at the end of the day,
it becomes not
an investable concept.
So, for that reason,
I'm out.
I would've loved
to have worked with you.
I'm a very big fan
of Momofuku...
Well, Thank you.
Thank you.
John: Here's what
I think about it.
My company, TurboPUP,
is going after
the same thing ‐‐
a lot of antioxidants
for hips and joints,
and it's a super food,
and we're doing great
with it.
But the valuation
of $11 million
for a product
that you've never put out,
I would be slapping my
TurboPUP partner in the face.
So, in the interest
of America,
I don't want you to ever,
ever, ever, ever,
ever, ever, ever, ever publicly
give that valuation again,
'cause you're
ruining people.
So, Daymond.
I'm out.
Thank you, Daymond.
I appreciate your feedback.
Where are we at
with Mark Cuban?
Look, I get
the proposition, right?
I'm not even mad
at the valuation
like these guys are.
Look, you've got to be able
to convince me
that you can get through to
enough sales of your product
to prove the concept...
Yep.
...and show some success.
When we're looking at the actual
sales and marketing plan,
it's a relatively minimal
sales and marketing plan.
What we've realized is
it's pretty viral.
So you're only gonna
be selling online.
We're only selling online.
Okay.
Is the goal to go back
to the lab
and introduce
15 new products?
No.
Or is the goal
to go from ‐‐
to kibble and just scale
where you're at?
To scale it.
The treat to enter the market.
Treats to enter,
then kibble.
So, there's a lot of people
like Kevin who have skepticism.
But the two products.
Two products. Two products.
You're not all of a sudden
going to
cats, pigs,
and aardvarks.
No.
So ‐‐ So, really,
what we want to do
is show success first.
We have the scaling
infrastructure.
We actually have the co‐packer
that can help us scale.
Okay.
I'll make you an offer.
I'll give you the $550,000,
but I need 10%.
10%.
I know that puts the pressure
on your investors.
Did you just eat
this dog food?
But I'm here for a reason.
Yep.
I'll put it back to you.
So, is there...
No.
I hear where
you're coming from...
No.
No?
So...
So, Mark, do you have
any flexibility whatsoever?
No. 10%.
So, there's not a whole lot
of negotiating.
You have to make a decision,
Ryan ‐‐ yes or no?
It's just a decision.
So, you know, at the
$9.5 million valuation,
that's where, you know,
my investors are at.
Don't you think
your investors realize
what Mark Cuban could do
for this company?
Of course.
Yeah, but it's not even
about me, right?
You knew when you said yes
to be on "Shark Tank"
that you were gonna
have to negotiate.
$550,000, 10% of the company,
and then we have a deal.
I'm ‐‐ Mark,
I'm willing to do that
even if that has
to come out of me.
‐Done.
‐Wow.
‐All right.
I would not
have expected that.
Thank you, Mark.
Appreciate it, buddy.
Thanks.
That's ‐‐ yeah.
That's great.
Yeah, thank you.
Yeah, it'll be fun.
Yeah, I can see it.
It may ‐‐
It may have to...
I understand.
Okay.
Appreciate it.
All right.
Thank you, guys.
‐Congratulations.
‐Well done.
‐I think you're both high.
‐Right.
You better take them dogs
to In‐N‐Out Burger.
They're about to faint.
Bye, vegan dogs.
All right, let's see ‐‐
they won't do any high fives.
If I were to say, you know,
who here in the Shark Tank
I would've loved to have made
a deal with, it was Mark,
so I know my whole team
is gonna be super excited,
and I'm really glad to
hopefully work with him
to really scale Wild Earth
into a multi‐billion‐dollar
company
that's really gonna make
the world better for our pets.
Congratulations, "Shark Tank,"
on 10 years.
When I pitched Parker's Maple,
I was only 18 years old.
We had about
$350,000 of sales,
and today we have almost
$3 million.
We've hired dozens of employees
and moved into
a brand‐new facility
off my family's farm.
Thank you, "Shark Tank,"
for giving me
and other entrepreneurs
just like me
the opportunity to truly fulfill
our American dream.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a family business
with the goal
of motivating kids.
♪♪
Greiner: Aww.
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Amanda.
And I'm Hamza.
And these are
our three little ones.
We're the family
from Shelton, Connecticut
behind Kudo Banz.
We're seeking $150,000
for a 10% equity stake
in our company.
Sharks, every day
around the world,
parents struggle with
the same parenting challenges
like potty training, tantrums,
and bedtime routines.
To help, parents have used
the sticker‐chart method
for decades.
It's a great go‐to
parenting tool that works.
It helps track
the kids' progress
and really motivates them
to listen.
The problem with
sticker charts is
they're always
stuck at home.
Let's go to the park.
That's why we've
invented Kudo Banz,
a better sticker chart
for your child's wrist.
Now, here's how Kudo Banz ‐‐
Wait, wait, wait,
Mom and Dad.
We got this.
It's time the kids
explained it.
Are you sure?
Yeah, come on.
We've grown up
on this show.
Amanda: All right, guys,
you're right. You've got this.
But where are you going?
Where are they going?
‐Okay.
‐[ Laughs ]
I hate to make children cry.
Hopefully they don't
make you cry.
I'm ready.
‐Oh.
‐[ Laughs ]
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Mika'il.
I'm Ayaan.
And this is Sofia.
Hi.
So, here's how
Kudo Banz works.
Kudo Banz starts
with a storybook,
where kids learn
that listening is fun.
At the end of the story,
they get a cool band to wear
and earn Kudos
for good listening.
Now, Sofia already
made her bed this morning
and ate lunch
without whining...
[ Laughs ]
...so she's already earned
herself two Kudos.
The third Kudo you earn
is a magical Kudo.
Hey, Mom and Dad, let's give
Sofia her third Kudo.
Sure.
It comes to life
with the Kudo Banz app,
and it's super cool.
Look.
‐Wow!
‐So cool!
That is cool.
And it unlocks
a customizable wheel
where kids get rewarded
for good behavior.
And kids pick
their own rewards,
like reading an extra book
at bedtime.
Or our favorite...
Together:
Family dance party.
♪♪
‐Get at that.
‐Wow, look at that.
[ Laughs ]
I still can't do that.
Kids love Kudo Banz
because it's fun,
exciting, and interactive.
And parents love Kudo Banz
because they finally have
a parenting tool
they can use
wherever they are.
Hamza: So, Sharks, who wants
to join our worldwide mission
to make parenting easier?
We have samples
for each of you ‐‐
our starter kit plus a special
Shark Kudo just for you.
Mika'il: For Matt,
we chose the lemon shark
for its curious
and resilient nature.
And for Lori, we chose
the Port Jackson shark
because they're unique,
fearless risk takers.
‐Thank you.
‐You're welcome.
And for Kevin, we chose
the great white shark
because you're powerful
and widely feared.
Absolutely.
For Daymond,
we chose the tiger shark
for its fashionable stripes
and go‐for‐the‐power‐
of‐broke mentality...
Tiger shark.
...when it comes
to its dinner.
And finally, for you, Mark,
we chose the bull shark...
Yeah.
...for its ability to adapt
and be successful in anything...
That's what
I'm talking about.
...salt or freshwater.
Greiner:
I got it on. [ Laughs ]
I'm not sure
I'm gonna get it off, but ‐‐
There you go.
[ Laughter ]
How old are you guys?
I'm 11.
I'm 9.
And I'm 6.
Greiner: So, in my bag,
I've got three bands,
and then I have
a bunch of ‐‐
There's a total
of six different charms.
‐Yep.
‐Mm‐hmm.
So, are there specific charms
for specific chores?
Actually not.
So, there's
a whole different collection
of charms you can get,
so parents will give
the charms to the kids,
and they'll select,
as they've done good listening,
each charm.
The third charm always
is that magical charm
that Mom and Dad puts on
the kids' bracelet
that comes to life.
Do those change?
Do you keep changing that,
or do they stay
the same rewards?
Mika'il:
It's customizable,
so you can add on
different rewards
based on different goals
you have.
Higgins: So, tell us a little
bit about, you know,
what inspired you
to create the product.
Hamza: Definitely.
I came home
one day from work,
and Amanda said,
"I had a moment with Mika'il.
He came home and told me that
I'm not a good listener."
And she was like, you know,
"I think it's our parenting.
You know, all these
time‐outs and negative ‐‐
he's drawing attention
to that negative focus."
And then she said,
"You know what?
I'm gonna make a product
that's gonna help
other moms and dads
across America
and the world."
We did a soft launch
mid‐year in 2017
to really learn our market
and the new category
we were creating.
Our big debut was at
the 2018 New York Toy Fair,
where we met
a lot of retailers.
So far,
our sales are $80,000.
Mika'il,
where do you go to college?
[ Laughter ]
$80,000 in sales
is not a business yet.
So let's talk about the strategy
for distribution.
We actually are selling it
all across the U. S.
But you're doing it
online, right?
Amanda: Online.
We're doing it online
on our website.
We're on Amazon.
What do you sell it
to them for?
What does it cost you
to make it?
Yeah, the starter kit
comes at $29.95,
which includes
the hardcover storybook.
Right.
We're talking
to buybuy Baby.
We met them at
the New York Toy Fair.
So yeah, we've got a great plan,
and it's not a hobby.
We're all‐in
on this business.
Amanda: Absolutely.
I actually resigned
from my hedge‐fund job
about two years ago
to jump into
entrepreneurship.
Greiner: Wow.
Amanda grew a firm ‐‐
she's a successful
entrepreneur ‐‐
with a 20‐cent investment
and took it all the way
to a million‐dollar ‐‐
Another company.
‐20‐cent investment.
To a million dollars?
Amanda: 20 cents
to multi‐million dollars.
And we have one of the most
successful companies on Etsy.
We are the top ‐‐ Go ahead.
You can tell her.
I know it's your favorite.
We're in the top 1%
of the 1% of the 30%
in the entire Etsy.
Wow.
I think you've achieved the
most important thing in life,
which is raised
a wonderful family.
I understand rewards
and token systems.
I know how many
there are out there,
and I'm just
not comfortable
that it's
differentiated enough
to be a big business,
so for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you.
Appreciate your time.
We understand. Thanks.
I'm currently
working on a book
that I feel might be
a conflict of interest.
We're sorry to hear that.
For now, though, I'm sorry.
I'm out.
I understand.
John: I had a company
that I invested in
in Season 2 called Flipoutz,
and the company
was creating bands ‐‐
not for the same thing ‐‐
but it's very hard
to have longevity
in the kids wanting
to wear the bands.
It kind of wears out
after a while.
So, with that, I'm out.
‐Okay.
‐Thank you, Daymond.
The fact that you have
all these awards is tempting,
but you're not worth
$1.5 million.
Nobody beat you up
about valuation,
and, kids,
this is important.
I'm gonna take
a Kudos from you.
‐Yeah, that's all right.
‐No taking Kudos away.
$150,000 for 10% is
a $1.5 million valuation.
That's a lot of money
for something
that isn't making
any money yet, but ‐‐
Our margins are huge,
though.
[ Laughter ]
We make the starter kit
and potty kit for $4.98,
and we sell it for $29.95.
O'Leary:
Here's your problem.
With $80,000 in sales,
you want a valuation
of $1.5 million.
There's no investor
gonna do that
until there's more
proof of concept.
And you're gonna
have to give up
some inordinate percentage
of your company
to just get the $150,000.
But our valuation is fair.
‐No, it isn't.
‐It is fair.
Higgins: [ Laughs ]
I love this kid.
It is fair.
He's got you speechless.
‐I understand.
‐He's stumped.
You ‐‐ he can't finish.
‐You don't know our assets yet.
‐It's very hard for me to ‐‐
Our assets are very good.
We have IP patents,
many patents.
Keep going.
I love this kid.
Love him!
I love it.
You want to take my chair?
I could give you some reasons
why it's not fair.
Kevin, all he's missing
is a big snout.
Let's not go there, okay?
He's a little you.
Look, I just think
it's too early.
I can't go down the path
with you.
I'm out.
♪♪
Thank you, Kevin,
for you time.
Thank you.
We appreciate it.
We really appreciate it.
Cuban: Well, guys,
congratulations
on what you've accomplished.
The challenge I'm having
is not whether you'll
be successful, right?
You guys are gonna
grind it out no matter what.
But sometimes that road
can be difficult.
But we're ready for it.
We are ready for this market.
But I'm gonna tell you ‐‐
There's nothing ‐‐
You cannot find a more
power‐packed team than us.
I'm telling you.
Sometimes you got to listen.
We work so hard.
You've clearly never
met my parents.
‐Okay.
‐They're amazing.
I just did. I have no doubt
they're amazing.
You're amazing.
But part of being a great
entrepreneur is listening, okay?
You've got some
immediate challenges,
and you haven't really
had the sell‐through ‐‐
this is what Kevin
was referring to.
I don't think
you're quite there.
You have some adjustments
to make.
Come on, Mark. Please.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out.
But congratulations on what
you've accomplished, guys.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Thank you for your time.
Mika'il,
I really like the way
that you stood up
for yourself.
You're doing better than most
of the adults that pitch here.
You're gonna be a future Shark,
so congratulations.
‐Amazing.
‐Thank you.
‐Thanks.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Thank you.
‐Appreciate it.
‐Thank you for your time.
Amanda: We're gonna
take this negative
and turn it into
a giant positive.
In a way, it's a gift
that they gave us,
because now we're out there
to prove ourselves,
and better believe it
that this team right here
is gonna do that.
Good job.
I'm so proud of you guys.
So proud of you guys.
You know, I'm so proud of
these kids right here.
I'm so proud of you.
Yeah, we took on the Tank,
and, you know, they're gonna ‐‐
they're gonna regret this.
They're definitely gonna
regret this.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a product
to help your pets
be camera ready.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Jason Hernandez.
I'm from San Diego, California.
I'm here seeking $100,000
in exchange for 20% equity
in my company, Pooch Selfie.
Sharks, I'm a dog lover.
I'm absolutely crazy about
my fur kid, here, Logan.
And like any dog lover,
I take a million pictures
of this little guy.
What I found is, for every
great picture I got with Logan,
it would take me
about 10 bad shots
before I got the right one.
You see, the problem was,
it was proving impossible
to get Logan to sit long enough
and look into my smartphone
for a great picture.
Now, I can't even tell you
how many times
I've had my face licked while
trying to get a great selfie.
‐Ah.
‐Ew.
So I searched and searched
for the answer to this problem,
and I found I wasn't
the only one struggling
to get great pictures
with their dogs.
Seemed like nobody had
figured this thing out,
and I knew there just had
to be a better way.
That's why I invented
Pooch Selfie.
Pooch Selfie is
a ridiculously simple device
which uses your dog's natural
draw and focus to a tennis ball,
and uses this power to hold
your dog's attention long enough
for you to capture
the best photos of your dog.
To use Pooch Selfie,
my wife, Erica, will actually
help us demonstrate.
Just take our universal
smartphone clip
and attach it to
the top of your device.
Next, grab one of our Pooch
Selfie squeaky tennis balls
and place it in
the clasping mechanism.
‐Wow.
‐And voílà!
You have instantly become
a master dog photographer.
That's great.
Pooch Selfie has been
an instant hit with dog lovers.
Take a look at some
of our happy customers.
Not only can you use
Pooch Selfie
to get fantastic selfies
with your dogs,
but you can also use it
to get some
pretty awesome portraits
of them as well.
‐Aww.
‐[ Chuckles ]
Now, I need your help
to get Pooch Selfie
in the hands of dog lovers
everywhere.
So, Sharks, who's ready
to help me change the way
we take pictures and selfies
with our fur kids
and show the world that you can
teach an old dog new tricks?
[ Chuckles ]
Do we get samples?
Yes, we have samples here
for you.
And then my wife, Erica,
is actually gonna take Logan
out to play some ball.
Cuban: See ya, Logan.
Bye, Logan.
Bye, buddy.
Erica: Good boy.
Thank you.
‐Thank you.
‐Kevin, here you go.
Daymond.
Thank you.
Mark.
Thanks.
Appreciate it, bud.
Thank you very much.
Okay, Jason,
how many Pooch Selfies
have you sold already?
I've sold about 15,800.
‐Dollars?
‐Good for you.
No, units.
Cuban: And what does
each of them sell for?
How many have you sold?
I‐I‐I'm sorry.
$380,000 worth of sales.
‐$380,000.
‐Sales.
‐That's respectable.
Each one sells
for $9.99 today.
And what's it cost you?
$1.30.
Is that landed with packaging
and everything?
That's land‐‐ That's sitting
in a warehouse, $1.30.
Good for you.
$380,000 in sales.
For the entire lifetime
of sales.
How many units was that?
Do you know how many units
you've sold?
Off the top of my head ‐‐
I have a little bit of
deer in headlights,
so I don't know...
Take a breath.
But do you know?
I mean, if you weren't
nervous right now,
do you have a good handle
on the numbers?
Yes, correct, I would.
So, take a breath
and tell us,
you know, give us
the whole picture.
[ Breathes deeply ]
25,000 units, approximately.
Are you doing this alone?
I am. I am.
So you're running
the business?
Every aspect ‐‐
everything that you see here
is completely done by me.
But somebody can knock this off
in two seconds, right?
Yes, but I am
U. S. patent approved,
so I have a patent here
in the U. S.
Utility?
A utility patent.
How have you sold them?
Online?
74% of our sales have done
completely at retail
by myself online ‐‐
online retail.
So, have you approached
any retailers
that sell dog stuff?
We do.
So, uh, we actually got them
into my dream retailer,
Bed Bath & Beyond.
This is something
that just happened.
They rolled them out into
tons of different stores,
but what happened is
they put it on a shelf
amongst all
the other dog toys,
and this really needs a lot
of customer education
for people to understand
exactly what it is,
make the impulse decision of,
"Oh, my God, that's really cool.
I need to get that."
So it got delisted
in Bed, Bath.
No, they did a markdown.
Tell us about your background.
Where did you ‐‐
Have you always been
an entrepreneur?
So, I went to school ‐‐
I'm a mechanical engineer.
I designed it, it got fine‐tuned
for manufacturability,
and then I actually took it
to China myself,
found the molder...
Good for you.
...and, you know, worked with
them to get the actual part.
‐Wow.
‐How much have you invested?
$18,000.
Cuban: Your own money?
My own money, correct.
‐Any loans?
‐No loans.
‐Any debt?
‐No debt.
Do you work on this
100% yourself at all times?
No, unfortunately,
Pooch Selfie is the dream job
I wish I could have.
It's not enough
to support myself
let alone my family.
So what are you doing?
I'm an electronics salesman.
I do that during the day.
We have a one‐year‐old
that is taking up my afternoons.
Congratulations.
And then this is what cuts
into the sleep.
So, what are you gonna do
with the 100k?
Actually, I would like
to redesign Pooch Selfie.
The product was made for two
of the most popular cellphones
out there today.
But there has been some pushback
on its compatibility
with, uh, other cellphones
that are out there.
So the next would be
redo the packaging,
because I feel that the
packaging that I put together
has limited
the shelf appeal.
And the rest?
Towards our follow‐up item,
which is the same concept,
but it actually holds a treat
instead of a tennis ball.
And why wouldn't you
do that right now?
Do you have
any inventory?
I have inventory of
the original Pooch Selfie.
How much?
18,000 units.
18,000 units?
Correct.
Well, that's
$180,000 worth.
That's your money
right there.
Yeah. No wonder
you don't have any cash
or are making
any money off of this.
Why would you not
just take your time?
You already have a day job
that helps feed your family.
Eat through
the inventory you have
and then retain 100%
of your company
instead of having
an investor here
that you have to report to
or consider?
Mm‐hmm.
Why would you do that?
[ Clears throat ]
This has been a lot of my life,
and it's, uh...
It's been really...
It's been really hard
to watch people
try to capitalize on the idea
and steal it.
I'm not only trying
to grow this business,
but I'm also, um ‐‐
I'm also trying to protect it,
and that's the stuff
that nobody sees.
[ Voice breaking ]
Nobody sees...
When you've created something
that nobody's ever seen before,
you watch so many people
just try to take it from you.
I made this because
I love my dog.
My dog's not gonna
be around forever.
That was my first
best friend.
And I just want
to share that with people
so that they can do
the same thing.
This entire product
has been my life.
I put this together
on my own,
no help from anybody,
and I've had people tell me
it's a fantastic idea,
it was a horrible idea.
But I made this.
I want Pooch Selfie to be
the number‐one brand name
for what people think about
when they want to take pictures
with their dogs.
Listen.
I, um...
My dog Spartan just died.
Aww, I'm sorry.
And, uh...
And I don't have any pictures
of him looking like that.
I could never
get him to look.
So I understand, you know,
the passion
to have something,
and also, you know, the love
of our little furry friends.
$100,000, 33 1/3%, right now,
I'll do the deal.
I'll take that risk with you.
Daymond, would you mind
if I hear any other offers?
I wouldn't do that.
Jason, I'm out.
I'm out.
Daymond, I'd love
to partner with you.
‐All right, smart man.
‐There you go.
Whoo. I was about
to take it back.
I was, 'cause I wanted you
to be decisive.
All right?
All right, congratulations.
Thank you very much.
Congratulations, Jason.
Great job.
♪♪
I've watched this show
for nine seasons.
Now I can't believe
I have a deal.
The Tank is not forgiving,
but I put it all out there.
I left all the passion
out there,
and I'm very, very happy
with the result.
When I was listening to
that passionate presentation,
I thought to myself,
"What planet am I on?"
[ Laughter ]
Greiner:
No, it wasn't...
You want to know something,
though?
I can remember exactly
what it felt like
when I was in his shoes
with my first product
and within literally weeks,
someone knocked it off.
And it's crushing,
because you know it's
unique and different.
and some‐‐
Lori, it happens every day.
Get over it.
Yes, but ‐‐
Where's your heart?
Oh, my God!
I live in the real world!
It's frigid.
Ice cold.
I live in the real world.
Everything gets knocked off.
Vampires do not have hearts.
You either litigate
or you run it in the market.
♪♪